this garbage patch and you sort of take
a bite to eat there's 180 times larger
chance that you eat plastic rather than
a piece of plankton right and what we
found was that this this concentration
is so high that it can actually have
this this chemical impact where where
these chemicals have a potential health
impact on these organisms as well as
species further up the the food food web
including us humans so have we noticed
that have people been tested and shown
to have ingested plastic that they've
gotten through eating tuna or something
like that so the plastic itself isn't
the thing that chemicals yes chemicals
that attach to the plastic and for
example you see is that for example in
Greenland like the the Native
communities that really rely on fish
they have much higher cancer rates they
have much higher concentrations of
mercury so other heavy metals as well as
these persistent organic pollutants he
thinks that attached you to press to the
plastic in Greenland
yeah like the like these sort of these
Native communities that rely on fish and
another sea life too so there this is a
recent trend that they have higher rates
of cancer yeah I don't know how recent
it is but probably past few decades I
can imagine but yeah that's really
linked to their their marine their
consumption of marine sources but you
know obviously it's hard to say well how
many percent of that is just heavy
metals yeah versus what's coming by
plastic but sure if you yeah if you look
at the kind of chemicals and you look at
the lab tests that they've done with
that those chemicals yeah they are not
very good for you now I've heard that if
you leave a water bottle like this in
your car and it gets hot out that the
water will plastic will leach into the
waters are correct yeah so I think it
depends on the kind of plastic but you
have I think with this your prey the
liner would contain like salads and
things like that
so yeah I wouldn't do that
so there's you know when you look at
those chemicals you have
you have two kinds of things you should
let they worry but one is the chemicals
that are actually in the plastic and
secondly there's these chemicals that
just float around in the ocean and then
can attach to the plastic when they yeah
because they sort of act like this
chemical sponge the plastic wants to
repel water and those chemicals too so
they kind of act like a magnet towards
each other especially the latter one is
it's well studied and we see that a lot
on the on the on the plastic but the the
former one yeah I mean it's even an
issue here if in your car for example
it's an issue in your car like how so
yeah well if you leave it like in a hot
car and right now a question was is even
if you're scooping out all that plastic
out of the ocean is it still leaving
chemicals that will we'll never be able
to get out so I think the chemicals must
be actually it collects more chemicals
than it sort of leach is that so because
of those those sort of legacy chemicals
like the the PCBs and DDT sort of things
that were used for insulators and
pesticides back into maybe the 40s to
60s so these these actually the plastic
attracts those chemicals so in a way you
can't even remove a bit of those
chemicals and we actually have to wash
them out before we do the recycling
because you don't want those in your
your products so there's actually some
sort of a benefit to having those
plastics in the water I mean now you
would encourage people to put in the
water but there is some some natural
benefit um yeah I mean it's sort of yeah
I mean I I cannot really say how many
percent of those legacy chemicals we
would be pulling out with the plastic
but yeah I mean you could say you could
argue it's sort of an added benefit to
removing it not to having plastic in
right now have you extended this line of
thinking to some of the other problems
in the ocean like these heavy metals
well so what I really hope is that the
area cleanup can sort of become a symbol
of how we should use how we should use
technology to solve problems
of our time so when you and I think a
lot of it comes down to that we
shouldn't sort of protest what we
shouldn't agree with but we should build
the things we should build a future that
we do agree with so when you look at the
past few hundred years of modernity in
our civilization what we see is dramatic
positive trends in terms of health
wealth education violence I mean it's
even Pinker on your show so I think
that's really really positive trends and
we've done a good job in that and that
all comes down to our ability to sort of
imagine things that don't exist yet so
sort of technology and innovation and
being able to work work together in an
effective way which is think about the
corporation so so I think those have
been a sort of very good trends and I
think what we should do is we should
also think about how to apply those to
the area outside of our own species and
to the rest of the environment because
when you look at all those positive
trends over the past few hundred years
and then you know that that's so good
but there's one very big exception which
is the impact to the environment it's
almost like we've had all the success at
the cost of the environment and but I
think that instead of there are some
people that have sort of a more
reactionary feel to this and they say
well look at all these problems it was
created by businesses and by technology
so we should stay as far away from those
things as possible and I think that's
sort of you know that's sort of stupid I
think that it really just shows that
these are very powerful ways of getting
things done and I think a much more
effective way was to apply that what has
worked in other areas and then also
apply that to the area of the
environment so so I don't think you know
for example think that the car problem
is not going to be solved by banning
cars I think it's going to be solved by
electric cars and I don't think the the
meat pollution problem is going to be
by every one becoming vegan I think it's
going to be solved by things like
lab-grown meat and and other kind of
alternatives so and that's why I also
think that yeah the urgent cleanup or
the plastic pollution problem is not
going to be solved by sort of people
trying to do their own little bit and
you know trying to live without plastic
or things like that I think is going to
be solved by you know things like
plastics that do not harm to the
environment as well as technologies like
the ocean clean up to sort of clean up
after ourselves
so yeah